[Applause]
well welcome everyone I'm assuming that
applause was not for me my name is bill
Flanagan and I'm the Dean of law here at
Queen's University and I am pleased to
welcome all of you here today for the
inaugural Liberty lecture generously
sponsored by Greg kuznetsky law 80 a
long time and very generous supporter of
the law school and Greg is here today
and I just want to tribe to join me in
thanking Greg for sponsoring this
lectures
[Music]
the Liberty lecture is intended to
explore the meaning of Liberty in our
contemporary society a subject of rich
interest to philosophers political
scientists and legal scholars just to
name a few
and today's Liberty lecture is moderated
by Professor Bruce party to my right of
the Faculty of Law an expert in a
variety of areas including environmental
law environmental law and governance
ecosystem management climate change
water law and university governance our
guest today is dr. Jordan Peterson a
professor of psychology at the
University of Toronto and a clinical
psychologist his many publications
include his recently published book
twelve rules for life an antidote to
chaos and his research spans a number of
topics including the psychology of
religion and the modern understanding of
creativity and personality I know that
today's lecture has generated a great
deal of interest as is evident from the
packed Hall here today it's also
generated a certain amount of heat the
proposed topic the rising tide of
compelled speech in Canada is for many a
controversial one and I know that many
of you in the audience will hold widely
divergent views I fully support your
opportunity to be heard and should you
wish challenge the speakers to defend
their positions I know that today's
speakers likewise share this conviction
and will welcome your comments and
questions as might be appropriate for a
lecture series named after Liberty I
believe it is also important for me to
affirm at the outset that the core
values of the Faculty of Law and of
Queen's University
include academic freedom and respectful
dialogue among those with differing
views this includes providing our
speakers with the opportunity to be
heard and providing all of you with
opportunity to respond in a respectful
environment free from any harassment or
any attempts to shut down the
conversation so it is in this spirit of
free and respectful academic exchange
that I am pleased to launch her this new
lecture series
welcome again and welcome to our guest
and I look forward to our discussion
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Bill
welcome and thank you for coming I would
like to underline what bill said which
is that this event would not have
happened without the initiative and
support of Greg kids s key so Greg thank
you very much as well before we start I
would like to thank some people from the
Faculty of Law Dianne Butler Adam Blake
calico and Christina Julian for their
help in putting this together I would
also like to acknowledge the support
help and generous assistance of several
people around the university lisa plater
and Event Services
David Paterson and the campus security
office you have been professional
helpful straightforward and I thank you
very much for making this possible I
would also like to return to Dean
Flanagan's observation about the
importance of this moment and to
acknowledge the role that both Dean
Flanagan and principal wolf have played
in enhancing the reputation of this
university in terms of its commitment to
academic freedom and academic debate
they have reflected an unflinching
commitment to those ideas as principal
wolf said on his blog informed
respectful debate is central to academia
and gentlemen I salute your academic
statesmanship thank you very much
[Music]
so we're going to proceed as follows the
first thing I would like to say is that
in the hall behind you afterwards there
will be some of Jordans
books on sale twelve whether it's the
title again twelve rules for life twelve
twelve rolls from I want to get the
twelve what it was right that's not
twelve steps it's twelve rules right we
are going to proceed as follows Jordan
and I are going to have a conversation
for half an hour maybe 40 minutes and
then we are going to throw the floor
open to questions will describe what
kinds of questions that you should ask
later on when we get to that stage but
our topic is the rising tide of
compelled speech in Canada I am going to
take just a couple of minutes to give us
some context and set it up and then I'll
ask Jordan to tell us what he thinks you
may have seen the CBC production of the
tutors the story of King Henry the
eighth's
in one episode the king has condemned
Thomas More to death for refusing to say
that the king is the head of the Church
of England more is it his cell awaiting
execution a friend comes to him to plead
with him to say what it is the king
wants to hear more says he cannot do
that for he does not believe it to be
true in exasperation the friends
you don't have to believe it you just
have to say it when your brain makes
that kind of calculation you know you
are under the thumb of a tyrant and
Thomas More lost his head the tide of
compelled speech in Canada is rising the
Law Society Ontario has introduced a new
policy that requires each lawyer to
develop a statement of principles which
endorses and acknowledges an obligation
to promote certain values the Ontario
Human Rights Commission says that under
the Human Rights Code failing to address
somebody by their preferred pronoun will
constitute discrimination for which you
may be investigated and prosecuted the
Elementary Teachers Federation of
Ontario has introduced new curriculum to
require teachers to teach elementary
students about white privilege and the
federal summer grants program requires
applicants to attest to the values that
the government believes it they don't
have to believe it
[Music]
[Applause]
that's pure narcissism at work by the
way
you don't to hijack to hijack an event
like this that other people put time and
effort into and to use they there are
their civility of the crowd and the
civility of the organizers as an excuse
to blatantly yell out your ill informed
opinions is no way to conduct a civil
dialogue it's absolutely appalling the
people who do that should be embarrassed
[Music]
all right I guess I would also say that
as students and as faculty members you
shouldn't put up with it there's no way
that you should allow people who are
doing this to hijack your educational
opportunities and to bend and twist the
functions and the structures of the
university it's it's not a good thing
not in any way at all I would say that
was a very disgraceful display
fundamentally so let's let's stick with
it why why do you think people are
afraid of free speech well you know
people develop an ideological view of
the world because they don't want to
think through things in real detail and
they're aided and embedded in that
endeavor by their pathological
professors who are feeding them what
would I say an oversimplified an
oversimplified radical view of the world
that in my estimation is fundamentally
based in in resentment not that there's
no reason for say a left-wing view of
the world and we can get to that later
it's it's easy virtue you know you can
stand up in front of nine hundred people
with your black art and your and your
screeching and you can you can be claim
to the entire audience your fundamental
moral superiority you can tell everyone
at once that they're all beneath you and
you're standing for the right thing and
absolutely none of that is earned you
know like what they hit what the hell
was that
there's its commissary man there's just
it's just complete misbehavior it's
embarrassing and the fact that people
the people who do that don't have enough
sense to go hide their head in shame you
just tells you how badly socialized they
are and how terribly educated they are
and the thing is the thing that's so
awful is that there are professors and
educators who promote that they say well
that's how you change the world it's
like it is how you change the world but
it's certainly not how you make it
better you make it worse clearly you
know there's no comfort in that and and
there's nothing about it that's
impressive it's no it's no better in
some sense than a two-year-old having a
tantrum on the floor it's a it shows as
far as I'm concerned it approximate the
same level of psychosocial development
so when the fact that that this is
happening continually at universities is
it's it it truly makes me embarrassed to
be associated with the University and
I say that with great displeasure
because you know I've been working for
great universities for a very long time
and the university is an absolutely
remarkable institution you know it's
survived for a thousand years and and to
see it to see it brought down by by
people whose behavior would be out of
place at a four-year-old's birthday
party is is something something visible
to behold so so what about the actions
of government now because it is
government after all that is the source
of this compelled speech as law as well
as other ways in which they seek to
restrict speech but the compelled speech
is the most egregious form a violation
I've been trying to sort this out
because you know if you're a clinician I
would say one of the problems you always
have when you're dealing with behavior
that's gone astray is to understand at
what level of analysis you should
address it you know is it a theological
problem is it a philosophical problem is
it a psychological problem is it social
is it economic like these are very
complicated questions is it a trivial
issue is it an issue of Rights is it
something else the people who put in the
bill c16 for example and its associated
legislation make the claim that it's
it's legislative loom that's facilitated
by nothing but compassion and desire to
expand the domain of of let's say of
Rights and Freedoms and you know there's
nothing wrong in principle with
expanding the domain of rights and
freedoms except of course for every
right and it and for every freedom
there's an attendant responsibility and
obligation so you have to keep that in
mind when I looked at bill C 16 and the
legislation that surrounded it
especially that was written by the
Ontario Human Rights Commission the
policies that surrounded it and also the
policies that gave rise to the social
justice tribunals named social justice
tribunals appallingly enough that that
gave rise to those tribunals and Ontario
the things I read just made my hair
stand on end you know the social justice
tribunals have the right to place
themselves outside of legal out of
outside of jurisprudential precedents
it's like what the hell is that
really you're gonna make the case the
only way I think that you could justify
doing that is that if you tortured
yourself into the ideological
proposition that English common law is
somehow an oppressive branch of the
patriarchy and because of that you have
every right and even obligation to place
yourself outside of its structure of
precedent but we don't want to place our
so outside of the structure of precedent
of English common law I can tell you
that it's it's one of the supreme
achievements of the human race it's it's
produced societies that are as free and
as productive as any societies have ever
been anywhere on the planet and
certainly are now and to dare to state
that you would place yourself outside of
that president that's the sort of thing
that made my hair stand on anton and
there are other elements of the policies
that were equally reprehensible not
least their complete incoherence of
formulation no I couldn't understand
some of it like I don't understand for
example with regards to the gender
propositions how it can be that you
could be anywhere on the gender spectrum
which by the way is not a spectrum
technically and it actually matters
which words you use if you're writing
law you can be anywhere or nowhere on
that spectrum like I don't know what
that means and I don't believe that the
people who wrote it know what it means
either and you don't write things that
you don't understand into the damn law
you don't do that because the law
unfolds in society and it tangles people
up as it unfolds and it's no joke when
that happens so you'd be very very
careful when you're writing law and you
certainly don't want to write law to
push forward your ideological
commitments especially in the face of
precedent because precedent is what
keeps law from degenerating into a
ideology essentially so so well and so
to answer your question you know more
more more more fundamentally I don't
believe that this argument has ever been
about the rights of transgender people I
think that it's an attempt by the
radical left ideologues to push their
ideological agenda forward using using
they're using attempts to manipulate the
linguistic domain and I'm not willing to
see dilute linguistic domain because I
don't think there are any more anything
more important than the words that you
use and then when the government says
well you should start
using these words you should start
thinking hard about your damn government
because your words are no different than
your thoughts and your thoughts orient
yourself your thoughts orient you in the
world and if someone's going to tell you
what it is that you have to think then
they're going to disorient you in the
world and I wouldn't recommend that
because there's lots of terrible things
that can happen to you and if you're
disoriented you're going to run into a
very large number of them so that's how
it looks to me so but about the
ideological context of this it seems
like something has changed yes because
if you think back decades earlier
liberals were the champions of free
speech yes it was the Conservatives at a
certain moment in time who were the
censors you know they they sought to
curb blasphemy and obscenity sedition
and so on and and the Liberals said no
free speech is the way we want to go and
yet today that has flipped if you if you
look back to what left-leaning officials
and authorities and and and figures said
let me just give you one quote this is
Samuel Gompers who is the founder of the
American Federation of Labor in 1886 he
said this he said the freedom of speech
has been granted to the people in order
that they may say the things which sorry
who's quoted that have not been granted
to the people in order that they may say
the things which please and which are
based upon accepted thought but the
right to say the things which displease
the right to say the things which may
convey the new and yet unexpected
thoughts the right to say things even
though they do are wrong now that is not
a sentiment now carried on by the left
and today what has happened well again I
see that it's a consequence of continual
a agitation by I would say a minority of
of the left radical left in
particular and those are people who are
Marxist / Neil Marxist in their
fundamental ideological orientation and
have joined that in an unholy union with
the worst of French post-modernism and
and they're they push it forward
ideological certainty and the thing that
the thing that's really distressing
about that is that if you know anything
about the history of oppressed people
let's say much as I hate to engage in
that particular form of dialogue under
the current conditions it's pretty
obvious that it's freedom of speeches is
a freedom that's particularly important
for people who don't have anything else
right it's if you're supporting freedom
of speech you're not supporting the
status quo I mean just think about let's
let's use the logic of the radical
leftists and assume that society is a
tyrannical hierarchy and the people at
the top have the upper hand in
everything including access to
communication
these people are not your friends you
say you know that's that that and mark
my words
that's the sounds of the barbarians
pounding at the gates right
[Applause]
yeah that's all I'll tell you again to
you soon inchoate what would you call it
inchoate sensation is the best
formulation of their argument and
there's not much difference between
knocking on the doors and knocking on
you so keep that in mind it's not
amusing there's nothing to it there's
nothing for it the thing that's also
quite appalling is that there's no
evidence whatsoever that the people who
are conducting these protests know what
it is that they're protesting against
you know I was in
[Applause]
all right I was in the midst of a
discussion attempting to make the case
that its freedom of speech that's that
is what people who have nothing still
have right so if you look at the
tyrannical structure of our society
let's say the people at the top have
access to means of communication
everyone knows that it's the people at
the bottom who have the right to say
what they think however badly they say
it that enables them to get a toehold
into the system into and to make their
suffering known that's what freedom of
speech is for and so like what's the
protest against that and I'll tell you
you know that the radical neo-marxist
types they speak the language of power
and that's what they're speaking right
now and if you want to live in a world
where everyone speaks the language of
power then just let them do what they're
doing and see what happens I wouldn't
recommend it it's not a pretty road and
you're all in a position you're on a
situation in your life now where you
have to make decisions about the sorts
of things like is this the sort of
institution that you want this to be now
one of the one of the arguments against
what you said about the pronouns was
that well after all all you're being
asked to do is to say something that is
reasonable it's not unreasonable to
address somebody by the pronoun that
they prefer and yet if you think of any
kind of speech which is proscribed
imagine a statute that said people shall
use the words hello and please and thank
you in their conversations that statute
is untenable yes because it now requires
people to use certain words in their
conversations even if those words are
reasonable themselves so that is not the
question and it was not your case you
are making that using a pronoun was in a
recent Boyd itself do I have that
correct well yeah first of all
there's a couple of things I'd like to
say about that no I looked at the
process by which the Ontario government
formulated its legislation with regards
to the pronouns and the consultation
process they used and the consultation
process was deeply flawed they contacted
activists and say let's activists of the
trans community okay well there's a
couple of things I'd like to say about
that the first is there is no trans
community right trans people are as
diverse as any other group of people and
to the idea that somehow because of one
of their attributes they constitute a
homogenous group is a well you think
that that would be a falsehood that the
people who are concerned about treating
groups of people adequately would be
loathe to to put forward but even more
importantly there's absolutely no
evidence whatsoever that the activist
types are actually representatives of
any of the communities that they
hypothetically activate on behalf of
it's like they're not elected they're
not appointed they don't pull they do
this they say look here's a group it's a
minority group and it's oppressed I'm a
member of that group and therefore I
stand for the group it's like actually
no you don't you don't stand for your
group you maybe stand for yourself you
know I don't stand for men and I don't
have to stand for white man I'm not I'm
not entitled to speak on their behalf
and so the idea that it's the trans
community that wanted this is a
completely unsustainable idea it's
certainly unproven I've had like 40
letters from trans people since I
started to engage in this call it
chaotic battle
and only one of them was mildly critical
of what I was doing all the other ones
there aren't that many trans people you
know so to get 40 letters is actually
quite a few I'm not saying that this is
a scientific poll but it's at least as
scientific as the process by which the
Ontario government generated its
legislation and and I'm not
and and I'm not generating legislation
and what these people said to a person
was I didn't ask to be the newest
whipping boy for the radical post
modernists all it's done has made my
life more difficult you know that basic
letter would say well I'm transitioning
from one gender to the other and it's
very difficult and I'm not sure that
it's the right thing to do and this has
made the process spectacularly more
difficult on all fronts it's like and
these people don't speak for me and just
because they say they do that doesn't
mean they do and so the other thing that
we seem to have swallowed as a society
is this crazy notion that well first of
all that we should be portioned up into
our different minority groups which i
think is a return to tribalism and
unbelievably dangerous I can't really
think of anything more dangerous than
that and then we've swallowed the idea
that if you identify yourself as a
member of a minority group and then you
bring forward a grievance you have to be
treated as if you're a valid
representative of that group it's like
well why in the world would we do that
it's guilt I suppose maybe that's part
of it or I think it's mostly guilt you
don't want to stand up and say well you
know who died and made you King so to
speak you know can we stay on that logic
for a moment the the idea so this this
compelled speech material seems to
insist upon treating people not as
individuals but as members of groups so
either blame them or to favor them as a
member of a group if we take that logic
and extend it you know that the group
identity thing becomes intersectionality
where you're not just belonging to one
group but you also have these
characteristics spin that up worse what
what
what is the logic of that where does
anybody use to well okay so the first
thing I would say to everyone in the
room is is I don't think and this is why
I decided to do with what I did right
from the beginning you know is that I
don't want to play the group identity
game I don't want to construe the world
in those terms but I'm not going to use
terminology that would require me to
formulate my thoughts in that manner I
think it's a terrible catastrophe to
divide us all up into our tribal
entities I don't see anything positive
about that at all so I just don't want
to go there and then second I would say
and maybe this is even more relevant you
may or may not have heard about
intersectionality but intersectionality
is a new development on the radical left
and I think it's actually if I wasn't so
intent upon seriousness in these matters
I would be constantly laughing about
intersectionality and the reason for
that is that it's the radical left has
discovered its own Achilles heel so look
what's the problem with dividing us up
into groups well there's many and the
descent into tribalism is not least
among them but the next is that well
then it turns out that we don't fit into
one group any of us we fit into multiple
groups and it's not obvious at all which
of those groups should take should be of
paramount importance you know there's a
racial group and an F of ethnic group
and there's groups of intelligence and
there's groups of temperament there's
groups of attractiveness and there's
groups of wealth and you can multiply
them really indefinitely and I do mean
indefinitely because you can categorize
a finite number of entities a virtually
infinite number of ways and so the
intersection lists discovered this they
said well there's there's let's say
there's Latinos and there's and there's
Asians it's like okay well wait a minute
there's male and female Latinos and
there's male and female Asians so so do
we treat is is the division into two and
off or do we need a division into four
well and then well then there's
socioeconomic class of male and female
Asians and male and female Latinos and
you can keep fractionating the groups
and technically without end and you
actually see this happening in real time
so to speak as the as the acronym for
the LGBT activists continues to expand
really without end and see what's at the
bottom of intersectionality and this I
suspect will be discovered eventually by
the radical leftist if they get that far
is that you have to fractionate the
groups right down to the individual and
that's what Western culture discussed
and articulated discovered and
articulated over the last 5000 years
it's like oh right the group isn't the
paramount division it's the individual
because unless you treat each person
like an individual you're not taking all
the intersections into account and so
it's extraordinarily it's
extraordinarily comedic but it also
isn't as if it's treating everyone as
they're an individual as if they're an
individual is an instant solution that
will bring us to utopia you know it's
it's like Winston Churchill said of
democracy right it's it's essentially
the least terrible approach we have and
life isn't the sort of problem that is
amenable to an instantaneous utopian
solution but our best bet is to meet
each other with the desire for peace and
productivity on this on this stage that
enables individual interaction because
then we meet soul to soul so to speak
and we also meet in a domain that we
bear responsibility for as individuals
and that's also extremely important
right you should be responsible for what
you say you should have to suffer the
consequences of what you say not least
so that you learn and so the individual
is paramount as far as I'm concerned I
think that's the fundamental principle
of Western civilization now it's not
only the West that has come across that
discovery but I think we've done the
best job so far of articulating it and
so we don't want to lose that because
the alternative isn't a multicultural
utopia the alternative is a descent into
tribal barbarism and and there are
people who would be just as happy if
that happened but I would system suggest
that it's not a destiny that in the wake
person with
would would long for yeah do you feel
like taking some questions do you feel
like taking some questions sure all
right so we're gonna have questions and
we'd like you to participate in this
conversation now please do ask a
question we welcome you up to say what
you'd like if there is a preamble to the
question that's fairly short then so be
it but please do ask a question we're
not actually anybody speeches and we do
primarily want to hear what Jordan has
to say so feel free to line up at the
two microphones we'll take one at a time
go ahead sir so first of all thank you
so much for being here I really enjoyed
it
and second I'm this ties into my
question I had just last week my free
speech coalition at bishops University
was officially ratified and I would love
to invite you to be our first guest
speaker if that's at all possible and my
question pertains to this for dr.
Peterson what would you consider the
most under discussed or overlooked ideas
and topics that you think should be
discussed in the club because I know
we're looking for controversial ideas
that we think are maybe not as discussed
as much as they should be well that's a
that's a difficult question I would say
that it isn't obvious to me that on
university campuses at the present time
or in the education system in general
we've done a good job of taking stock of
the advantages and disadvantages of our
current socio-political systems
now and I think there's enough data so
that we could start having intelligent
conversations so one thing I would
recommend to you all if you're
interested is a book I just finished
reading it it's called the great leveler
the great leveler by Walter shy del and
it's a discussion of inequality and it's
a very intelligent book so one of so
inequality as you may or may not know is
rife throughout human societies right
and that's the case in the present day
and it's being the case historically but
it's also the case in animal societies
by every measure so inequality is the
rule of life let's say and that doesn't
mean it's not an ethical catastrophe I'm
not saying that I'm just saying that the
fact of inequality cannot be laid at the
feet of the West or of capitalism or
really of any human construction for
them matter one of the things shy Dell
did was to investigate empirically the
relationship between inequality and the
pole of government so because let's say
if you if you surveyed a very large
number of states you could determine
whether this the governments were
left-wing or right-wing and then you
could you
do a compilation of inequality
coefficients and you could find out if
left-wing governments had any any
ability to ameliorate inequality just as
an empirical question and the answer
that shy Dell generated was no there's
no difference whatsoever in the
inequality coefficients in left and
right wing states and what that points
to is a much more fundamental problem
and the shy Dell in his book also points
out that the only known historical
forces that limit inequality or that
reduce inequality are war Revolution and
pestilence it doesn't look like it's
easily under under human control and so
you know the Marxists talked about
inequality and the fact that capital
tends to accumulate in the hands of
fewer and fewer people which is sort of
true except that the people at the top
tend to rotate a lot more quickly than
that then the Communists and the
Marxists every presumed but it doesn't
look like that's a consequence of
capitalism it looks like it's a much
deeper process and capitalism at least
well it's shoveling money and resources
up to the top also does lift the bottom
very very quickly you know and this is
something we need to have a serious
discussion about in the Universities so
like one because we shouldn't be doing
this we should be partying in the
streets and here's one reason why do you
know that the level of absolute poverty
in the world fell by fifty percent
between the year 2000 and the year 2012
you know that was three years faster
than the most optimistic UN projection
considered it was the fastest decline in
absolute poverty that the world has ever
seen
and like that's a big deal you know
about there's hundreds of thousands of
people a week right now that are being
connected to the power grid and almost
everybody has access to high-speed
computation and the the these struggling
economies in Africa have for the last
four years being the fastest growing
economies in the world you know there's
almost no absolute privation left there
aren't people starving except for
political reasons we're at a point where
obesity is the worst worse problem than
starvation you know and and now I also
think that a lot of that was purchased
out the cost of the of the dreams and
hopes of the working class in the West
you know I think what we did some sense
about a 30-year period was sacrificed
the aspirations of the Western
working-class to alleviate poverty in
India and China
and in Southeast Asia and it looks like
that might have been a really good deal
although it was a little bit hard on the
working-class people and that has to be
taken into account but we're not having
discussions of this sort universities
it's like we're stopped in 1980 or maybe
in 1960 we haven't updated our bottles
to take into account the new and often
extraordinarily positive realities and
we're tearing ourselves apart in the
West with this identity politics idiocy
at the same time the things are getting
better and better faster and faster than
they ever have by a huge margin in the
history of mankind so it's like it's
time to wake up and throw off the
depression of the Cold War and and to
look around and see what's what's
available in front of us and what we
could accomplish that would be much
better than oh yes yeah
[Music]
I am told that there are developments
outside I'm sorry for the noise the
they're doing the best they can
yes yeah hi so mr. Peterson you've said
that your problems are one of your
utmost priorities is the pursuit of
truth could you just clarify what truth
you mean when you're presented with a
situation where you have to or you're
being asked to refer to someone to their
preferred pronouns is it is it a truth
that you see is it their truth is your
truth to be the issue isn't the request
of the individual to be addressed in a
certain manner
it's the compulsion of that by law so
and these issues get conflated
constantly look I've dealt with all
sorts of people in my life a much
broader range of people than most people
ever encounter in the course of their
entire lives and I'm perfectly capable
of deciding how to treat someone on a
one-to-one basis but when the demand for
for terminology becomes part of the
legal system I don't care what rationale
is it's not happening as far as I'm
concerned and people say well we're
pushing it forward because of compassion
and maybe you could stop just being such
a mean professor it's like why should I
believe that you know what the hell
you're doing with your compelling laws
you're willing to you're willing to move
past a legal line in the sand that's
been drawn for let's say 700 years you
do not write compelled speech into the
legislation oh but we're doing it with
the best of intense yeah no you're not
so these issues have to be separate look
if this was about transgender rights it
would have disappeared in September of
it's not about transgender rights and
everyone knows it so this is not about
transgender rights what these what these
people are doing outside it's about
something far deeper than that
can we ask the question this wait can we
say don't doesn't everybody have the
rights the Liberty to decide how to
present them
you know how to be who they want to be
what to wear you know what gender to
call themselves and the answer is yes
everybody has the Liberty to do that but
everybody else has Liberty to and the
Liberty to do that doesn't mean they
have the right to compel other people to
agree with it
in other words Liberty is not the right
to demand that the world validates the
choices that you've made you have your
choices you have the freedom to make the
choices and everybody else has the
freedom to make their choices to and to
approve or disapprove but they call you
this well they call you that in other
words Liberty is a two-way street and
everybody has it and the fact that
you've made choices doesn't mean
everybody else doesn't have the same
ability to make the same choices
oh yeah backpack my place dad hi that
was loud I just want to thank you for
being here I'm really a big fan and I
have a bad habit of making or getting
into arguments with a lot of radical
leftist and I'm the most common argument
they present to me generally is Bill c16
only covers the Ontario Human Rights
Code so those are protected areas under
the Ontario Human Rights Code such as
universities elementary schools etc I
was just wondering how you would combat
this argument seeing is their argument
is generally they're only dealing with
vulnerable groups such as young students
and it doesn't matter they say well it's
it's restricted in scope
yeah it's not restricted enough look I
mean here's a couple of facts okay so
when I first made my videos about Bill
c16 one of the things that I suggested
was that the act of making the video
itself could well have been illegal and
of course people immediately accused me
of fear-mongering and perhaps with
reason it's not always easy to
understand the full intent of a new
piece of legislation surrounding
policies but I can tell you one thing
when the lawyers at the University of
Toronto read through the new legislation
and the surrounding policies they also
decided that what I was doing might have
been transgressing the law and that's
why they wrote me two letters telling me
to stop okay so that's fact number one
okay fact number two two words
Lindsay Sheppard
[Music]
okay so let's say for the argument that
I'm a paranoid megalomaniac and that I'm
a bigot and all of the other things that
people have decided that I might be okay
well I'll tell you what in my paranoid
megalomania I never envisioned a
situation where a teaching assistant a
22 year old teaching assistant at a
major Canadian university would be
hauled in front of a quasi Maoist
Inquisition and have to record it
because she dared to show five minutes
of a video from a mainstream news
program run by Public Television funded
by the government of Ontario so paranoid
as I was let's say it isn't obvious that
I was paranoid enough so and I don't see
that I don't see how either of those
examples can be disputed you know it
wasn't like the University of Toronto
wrote me two letters without thinking
about it they went and consulted their
high-powered lawyers and the lawyers
reviewed the policies in the legislation
and they thought oh dr. Petersen he
might be contravening that legislation
it's like it was a weird that
paradoxical gift to me that they sent
out those two letters telling me to stop
because it was instant proof that what I
was doing was I wouldn't say right
because god only knows about that but at
least if my interpretation of the bill
and its intent was correct so we just
make this observation that that's that
response to Jordan's critique of c16 the
one that went oh he's overreacting
nobody's going to be punished or sent to
jail for this is silly
in this sense remember every single
legal rule there is is a legal rule only
because it is backed with the
monopolistic violence of the state there
there's no such thing as a rule without
punishment so if if for example there's
a no parking sign what the parking sign
says oh by the way please don't park
here but there are no tickets well
people are going to park because that's
not really a rule so if you have a rule
in the Human Rights Code and if you
breach it if that's discrimination
well then true that the first thing that
happens to you is not going to be thrown
in jail but there's a process a series
of steps right the first one might be a
mediation or an investigation and then
there might be a fine and then if you
don't pay the fine then your wages might
be garnished or you might be ordered to
fix it but believe me if you refuse and
refuse and refuse and refuse that order
will become a court order and then if
you don't obey the court order you'll be
in contempt of court and then that will
lead to arrest and imprisonment so every
single rule in the Human Rights Code is
effectively enforced with the most
severe violence the state has even
though it's not actually practiced most
of the time because most people obey we
also don't want to underestimate like I
don't know how many of you have had the
pleasure of being dragged before a board
that investigates your behavior but I
would tell you that even if you don't
end up paying a fine or in jail there's
nothing particularly Pleasant about the
process itself it's enough you know you
wonder why people don't speak up and I
can tell you one of the reasons they
don't speak up is because merely being
dragged in front of a board of inquiry
innocent or guilty is enough to pretty
much do you in for a whole year
like if you're a sensible person that
you're concerned with propriety and and
you want to maintain the stability of
your life and your reputation is
important to you perhaps because of the
stiffest ability of your family depends
on it to be investigated for such things
as a punishment all of its own it's no
it's no pleasant business and many of
you will experience that I would
I would equate being investigated by our
a non-punitive port let's say with these
punishments that Bruce describes quite
far down the distance I would equate
that to having a fairly serious disease
in terms of its in terms of its
psychological and physical impact I
would also say you don't know I won't
stand let's go with it
thank you as embarrassing as what's
happening out there speeds University I
think what it doesn't want to hate to
show how we're doing here is how we
thank you
[Music]
in terms of my question that most with
your belief that it's extremely
important and everything that we're
doing to speak our mind to speak freely
that's why we're here but in terms of
practicality there's a lot of things to
get are in the way of our lives with
students you know we have our TV a
little poor job prospects so um in terms
of practicality what are kind of living
your tips in your perspective on the
steps that students can take to kind of
speak their mind while not sacrificing
well I can tell you a couple of things
that are very practical don't write in
your essays what you think the professor
wants to hear there's absolutely no
excuse whatsoever for doing that now
first of all most professors even those
who have descended into an estate of
ideological possession let's say most of
them had still have enough character to
grade an essay that's well written
properly so you're actually taking less
of a risk than you would think by
stating what you have to stay but look
if you start practicing when you're in
university the mistakes are rather low
pandering to the audience let's say and
say what you think will get you by
you're gonna train yourself to do that
and once that means is you're gonna
train yourself in the falsification of
your character and your character is the
only thing you have to guide you through
life
no people dream of riches and they dream
of luxury and all of that but that's a
Finney defense against the harsh
realities of the world you have your
character and so what you do when you go
to university is you learn to say what
you think as clearly as you can and to
take the slings and arrows that come
along with that
not in an arrogant manner right because
like what the hell do you know you know
so you've got plenty to learn but you
want to formulate your thoughts
carefully you want to write what you
think
well why because when you're writing
your thinking you're laying out the
arguments that you're going to use to
structure your existence in the world
throughout your entire life and if you
start to twist and Bend those four
expedient reasons you're gonna warp your
soul and I mean I could talk about that
neurophysiological II if you want to you
know you become what you practice
you automate what you practice so if you
automate
expedience speech for the sake of
short-term gain then that's what you're
gonna produce you're gonna produce
expedient speech for short-term gain
well god help you if you do that like
there is nothing that you will possibly
do in your entire life that will serve
you better than to get control of your
voice in university let me see you do
that by reading right you read great
people you do that by writing what you
think you stay true to yourself while
you write what you think and you take
the risks and you gain the benefits that
go along with that you learn to stand up
and speak and to listen carefully and
that makes you a negotiator of
unparalleled power and if you're a
negotiator of unparalleled power there's
nothing in the world that won't open
itself up to you so that's what you're
doing in university and if you find
professors who who reject that and
there's fewer of them than you might
think then it's your sacred obligation
to stand up for yourself against that
because it's gonna happen to you
throughout your whole life and you might
as well start practicing how to do it
right now so that's how it looks to me
yeah there's an old saying that I I
write
[Music]
I write in order to know what I think
and you'll note how compelled speech
interferes in that process yes so it
idea that you have to write what your
professor wants is the form of compelled
speech it's like it I really do believe
that this is a fundamental issue as a
therapist say when I'm trying to help
someone set their life straight I do my
best not to compel their speech and the
reason for that is quite clear it's like
you have your destiny with all its
attendant triumphs and sufferings and
it's on your shoulders
I don't want to tell you how to think I
don't want to tell you how to think
because I do not know how you should
think you have to figure that out for
yourself
and and then you have to bear the
responsibility for that and you you're a
terribly arrogant fool if you dare to
tell someone else how it is that they
should conduct themselves through life
now I mean having said that well
obviously I say well you should tell the
truth or at least you should lie but
that's not a dictate of of prov of
action so to speak it's a dictate of
process it's like well you can't you
shouldn't interfere with the mechanism
that allows you to solve all the
problems that you will face in your life
and you come to university maybe to
prepare for a trip for a profession you
know and to set yourself up economically
but to set yourself economic up
economically properly I don't care what
your profession is going to be there is
no one who is more powerful than someone
who can communicate it doesn't matter
what the field it doesn't matter if
you're a plumber or a politician if you
can formulate your thoughts clearly if
you can conduct yourself honorably in
your action and your speech if you're
articulate and careful then the the
world opens itself up to you you have an
unlimited horizon of possibility so
thank you both for coming but firstly
I'd like to thank everyone in the room
who has not devolved into the hysteria
we see outside they would prefer that we
lost our sanity and that our society
would fracture into the nonsense we see
so by sitting here being as patient as
you are this is how we keep our Academy
this is how we keep our society thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
my question is a simple one we see more
and more this new language I call of
leftism intersectionality equity
diversity inclusion and we see people
from all political and philosophical
stripes adopting this new vernacular is
this in any way dignifying that as a
position is this dignifying the
philosophical basis of these words do
people recognize that when they use
these lengths these words that they're
making that somehow a truth that we all
ought to accept I don't should we or
should we not I don't think people do
recognize that again you know what I'd
like to reiterate with the reason I made
those videos to begin with was because I
don't I was unwilling to cede the
linguistic territory as soon as you
think it's already happening to some
degree so imagine that we just define
the socio-political landscape in terms
of identity politics which is happening
very rapidly in fact we're compelled to
do so right so um well then then what
happens is you get activity on the
identity politics front on the left and
on the right the left says well the
oppressed shall rise and take their
rightful place and the right says yeah
over my dead body
and probably yours too so as soon as we
play the identity politics game that's
where we're at and we start playing it
by accepting the terminology you know
already I find myself stumbling when I
use the word sex instead of gender and
that's not good like I have to
consciously overcome a resistance to use
the word sex instead of gender because
you know I'm actually quite an agreeable
person and it actually pains me to to go
against the crowd let's say you know I'm
not temperamentally suited for it
precisely
strangely enough and so I feel the
compulsion to use this kind of language
welling up inside of me just to be to be
nice I suppose you know but I know where
identity politics leads it leads to the
gulag it leads to the concentration
camps it leads to blood in the streets
we don't need that here we're doing
pretty well so we
leave it hi professor Peterson I studied
history for the duration of my degree
and I think it's just sickeningly ironic
that the people who are using their free
speech want to take away your free
speech and furthermore that they can't
see the irony of the situation of how
tyrannical their being my question is
however I've noticed from a lot of what
you've talked about and I've been
watching you since your rise in 2060
2016 and I know that you're a Christian
and I don't want to divulge into that
but I noticed a lot of the sort of North
American Protestant work ethic in in in
your lessons like you know self
redemption and to be your own person
like we've been talking about that the
last like hour and a half I suppose and
in a ever rising tide where people are
rather in the Western world where it's
becoming increasingly rather
decreasingly Christian specifically is
yeah decreasingly religious and
specifically decreasing the Christian
how can you what do you think is the
best suggestion in order to be able to
uphold those such important values that
have been across the world from American
cultural influence I apologize for the
long question no no it's fine
you know people have asked me repeatedly
about my religious views and I've
answered them in a variety of different
ways but they say do you believe in God
let's say and my response to that always
is well I don't know what you mean when
you ask me that question so I don't know
how to answer it I don't know what you
mean by belief but I can tell you
something that I believe and I would say
this is a way of speaking symbolically I
do believe so I was thinking the other
day a week ago I was thinking about this
little fantasy that entered my mind I
was thinking about st. Joseph's oratorio
in Montreal and st. joseph´s oratorio is
a very large religious building it's one
of the biggest cathedral like structures
in the world and it's set on the hill
won't Royal and it's set up where it can
catch the Sun you know so it's an image
of the heavenly City on the hill right
it's an image of the structures that
we strive to create that's what it is in
independent of its specifically
Christian or religious function that's
what it stands for symbolically okay so
it's the city on the hill it's it's what
we're striving towards when we walk
uphill in life
okay now the way the oratorio is
structured there's hundreds of steps
leading to it up the front and in the
early part of the 20th century a lot of
people who had physical disabilities
came there and they struggled up the
step on their crutches and many of them
left their crutches in the oratorio you
can see hundreds of them if you go there
it's quite an interesting sight
and I was thinking about that and I was
thinking about what that meant this is
what it means it means that you know
everyone has their disabilities let's
say and I know that some people are far
more terribly affected than other people
I'm perfectly aware of that but the
question is what do you do about that
and what you do is you you set yourself
up on your damn crutches and you
struggle up the bloody hill that's what
you do and you struggle up the hill
towards the kingdom of God that's what
you do because the alternative is to
descend into the abyss that's the
alternative and then so to say well do
you believe it's like I believe that you
should struggle uphill towards the City
of God on your crutches that's what you
should do that's the opposite of the
descent into the abyss and so that's
that's at the foundation of our
civilization that idea well argue with
it if you will see if you can figure out
why that's not an acceptable idea maybe
you should help someone struggle up the
hill perhaps you should you know you can
lend a hand to someone although you
don't want to take the burden away from
them entirely because there's something
noble about struggling up the damn Hill
right there's something that's adventure
that's the call to proper being it's
like well we don't need to forget this
you know we don't need to forget it the
universities have been there since time
immemorial to try to push that idea
forward through the generations and
everyone needs to know that idea that's
what gives you life not happiness forget
about that if it comes well great accept
it dignity nobility character truth
responsibility beauty
those are the things to aim for honor -
I'd say honor thank you very much and I
hope when all this is done I hope you
take a nice long big vacation hello dr.
Peterson first thank you for coming and
so I'm Chinese my parents grew up in the
Cultural Revolution of China so I took
particular attention when you mention in
multiple occasions comparing what's
happening the West right now to miles
China and I I agree and it's pretty
obvious the connection between their
ideology the identity politics and the
oppression versus up oppressed
viewpoints but my question is mostly
about how they're promoting the
political agenda I mean I see that the
political agenda the philosophy behind
the political agenda are very similar
but at the same time I see a shocking
similarity in the way that they're
promoting that political agenda
specifically backing back in the
Cultural Revolution anyone who dared to
say anything that it's not fully for the
movement was classified as NT
revolutionary just as now who anyone who
dare to say anything that goes remotely
not fully aligned with whatever they
want to promote is classified as hate
speech although it has nothing to do
with hate hating anybody so since the
same thing is happening here and a mouth
china
what would you say well what what do you
think is the connection between the
philosophy and their idiotic
oversimplifying and tyrannical way of
trying to promoting it well the first
thing the first thing we should make
clear is that there is such a thing as
hate speech right like let's not be
naive about this and you can use words
to inflame and words can be very
dangerous tools and people use them in
hateful manners all the time that's not
the issue
that's obvious the issue is whether or
not you should regulate that and even
more importantly whether the state
should regulate it and the reason that's
an issue is because who's going to
define it I'll tell you who's going to
define hate speech it's the people who
are doing that that are going to define
hate speech and right now they're
defining you sitting in here as hate
speech I mean that's
what's going on while we sit here it's
like who would be interested in defining
the parameters of hate speech here's the
answer the people that you would least
want to have adopt that responsibility
and and hate speech is like let's say I
was interviewed a while back and the
journalist asked me well why should your
right to offend Trump someone's right to
be secure it's like okay well let's say
I'm talking to one person and you might
say well I don't have the right to
offend them all right what if I'm
talking to ten people do I have the
right to offend one of those people when
I speak to them what if it's a thousand
people
look you can't you can't have a
conversation about something serious
without offense like if I'm thinking
about something serious like I offend
myself you know and I'd seriously mean
that I really mean that so like if I'm
laying out a set of hypotheses for
example about a complex social social
problem
I might lay out 20 hypothesis and maybe
two of them I think God I hope that's
not true but like maybe it is true you
know sometimes you discover things as a
social scientist that you wish were true
and those are usually the things that
you've discovered that are actually true
right because they violate your
assumptions so you can't even think if
you're not willing to offend yourself
that's what thinking does if you're ever
talking about if it didn't have the
possibility of frightening and offending
people that's kind of how that's kind of
like the definition of seriousness it's
like well we can only talk about things
that no one ever gets upset about it's
like well then it's like you're trapped
in an elevator for for the rest of
infinity listening to nothing but music
you that's and that's a kind of hell man
if you're gonna think and also if you're
gonna speak you're gonna you're gonna
offend people you're gonna go after
their deepest presuppositions and your
own as well
you're gonna shatter them at times it's
gonna be brutal absolutely brutal and
you all know that because every single
one of you has had a serious
conversation with someone that you love
and the probability that that was an
easy conversation and that either of you
escaped without offense and terror is
zero if you haven't had a conversation
like that well well you're not human
right I mean right because everyone has
conversations like that all the time
except when they run from them which is
most of the time and no bloody wonder
you know real conversations are there's
nothing worse than a real conversation
except the war that you have if you
don't have the conversation that's
basically how it goes
I just want to underline
I just want to underline Jordans first
point which is really that it's a very
dangerous thing any legal rule that
relies on some kind of reasonableness
because reasonableness lies in the eyes
of the beholder
I mean those people out there think that
you guys are uttering hate speech they
think that you guys should be the one
who are arrested and just imagine if
they were the ones who had the reins of
government power just all very well but
think of hate speech is a reasonable
idea but as soon as you give up the
control about what that means you're
liable to run into a real trouble next
hello mister well mr. Peterson my name
is Zachary Milligan
first off I'd just like to start by
actually thank you for all the hardship
and troubles you've endured for standing
up for our rights and being a part of
this debate I come from a dairy farm and
matheny rural raised conservatively and
my question is in the face of when we
have a social situation so divisive when
you genuinely believe what you're doing
is the right thing in this particular
instance since you have experience with
it what would you say is there a more
effective I don't want to say an easy
way to reach out for them but what do
you think's the best way to try and talk
some sense into those folks outside and
the one-on-one setting so the first
thing is is I don't necessarily did I I
don't necessarily think that what I'm
doing is the right thing because you
know you have to be careful when you
make a claim like that but I can tell
you one thing I'm not going to let
anyone stand in the way of me trying to
figure out what the right thing is
that's the thing
[Applause]
and then I would say we're doing exactly
what we should be doing right now in
this discussion it's it's just exactly
right right I mean admittedly we have to
talk over the noise but that's really
not that big a catastrophe and everybody
in here is comporting themselves in a
reasonable manner and we're trying to
struggle our way through the topics and
we're we're asking questions and we're
trying to have a genuine dialogue about
them and that's what we've got we've got
that we've got three things we've got
negotiation
we've got slavery and we've got tyranny
and those are your choices and so this
is negotiation right that's public
discourse and the reason that freedom of
speech thought is obviously important
everyone can understand that you might
say well you don't need to speak freely
because you can think who's going to get
inside your head but the problem with
that is that that's not it
you can't think very well because there
you are in your little world you know
with all your biases and your ignorance
you're wrong about so many things and
you're gonna learn it really painfully
and and then maybe you can trot out some
of the things you think erroneously and
ignorantly and other people will give
you a tap on the side of the head
instead of running you over with a
freight train right they'll give you a
little tap on the side of the head and
maybe you'll walk away a little smarter
and that's why freedom of speech is so
important is because a lot of thinking
especially about things that are beyond
you for whatever reason have to take
place publicly as we stumble around
towards an adequate formulation of the
problems that beset us so I would say
well in this book I wrote I have a rule
it's I think it's rule eight which is
tell the truth or at least don't lie I
would say well that's another reasonable
reasonable way to start approaching the
situation is it's not so easy to tell
the truth because like what do you know
you know you can't come out and say well
here's the truth but I know what one
thing you can do which is when you know
that what you're saying is a lie by your
own standards you cannot say it and you
can have a consultation with yourself
and you can try to learn to say those
things that make you
strong instead of saying those things
that make you weak and you you
contribute to the health of the public
dialogue in incalculable manner that way
and this is another issue that pertains
to the dignity and importance of the
individual how you conduct yourself in
your life is way more important than you
think and I mean I think that that's a
daunting idea because you know let's say
you're nihilistic and life is
meaningless well what's the payoff for
that I think well there's no payoff it's
like well yeah there is you have no
responsibility that's a pretty decent
payoff I mean you have to pay the price
of meaninglessness but it doesn't matter
what you do well we'll flip that over
and say no no sorry you're wrong your
life is meaningful it's way more
meaningful than you think but you have
to bear a responsibility for your
thoughts and your actions it's like
you'll there'll be plenty of meaning in
that well that if you understand that
property that will that will sleeve you
to the depths of your soul and maybe you
learn to speak carefully and to act
carefully and that will have a
beneficial effect on everyone around you
if far more you're far more powerful in
the place you stand in the place you sit
and stand than you think and I think
everyone has an intimation of that and
if you don't think that's true
then try treating people around you as
if it's not true try treating people
that you know in your life as if they
don't matter
and just see what kind of response you
get people are not going to be happy
with you not in any sense whatsoever
you'll you'll ruin all your
relationships you have to treat people
as if they matter and maybe you have to
treat them as if they matter because
maybe they do and that goes for you too
and so if you matter then you should act
like you matter and that's a very that's
a very daunting proposition that's for
sure and as a as a
it's just a footnote to that let's just
observe this in legal terms there are
only two categories of actions voluntary
and involuntary don't let anybody tell
you otherwise
either you're choosing on your own and
and handling the consequences or the
government is telling you what to do
those are the only two possibilities at
the back go ahead
Oh doc Oh dr. Peterson I would like to
recall the part in your conversation in
which you mentioned how the radical left
switched from the 1960s and 70s to being
back when they were a pro free speech
and their recent opposition to it I know
I know that you often mention their
obsession with power at least among them
yes at least among their more Marxist
types I was one wondering if perhaps
they think that now you know that now is
the opportunity where they can
consolidate their power and if they do
so successfully that it will become the
morality of our civilization for the
next thousand years like Christianity
was when Rome adopted it is that from
what you've seen would you say that
that's about that that's close to the
way they're that's close to their
strategy well it's hard to exactly
understand the strategy of an ideology
you know because all the people who were
outside were were united in some sense
under the umbrella of an idea and an
idea as a living thing I mean it's it's
embedded in living tissue and it's
distributed in the fragmentary manner
across the mob let's say and each person
in the mob is only only possesses a
fragment of the ideology because the
full neo-marxist let's say the full
neo-marxist postmodernist doctrine is
quite calm
black sand and but when you get the mob
together then it acts under the dictate
of the ideology and the question then is
well what does the ideology want and I
would say well it wants what its
formulator says it wants and Derrida for
example whose head Trixter of the post
modernists regarded the Western society
as fellow NGO centric right and north
that meant was male dominant
male-dominated that's the fellow fellows
part and then logo centric while that
refers to the word logos which means is
the root word of logic but is also the
is also the the person of Christ
essentially the logos and so and the
purpose of the postmodern critique was
to demolish that well fair enough my
sense with people is especially if
they're if they've written things down
and thought them through that they're
actually aiming for what they say
they're aiming for well if you if you
buy the idea that the West is a
male-dominated tyranny essentially a
patriarchal tyranny and that your moral
duty is to tear it down well then that's
what you're doing and then you might say
well what's going to what is going to be
erected on its ashes well that's where
things get complicated you know the
first question might be are the people
who wish to tear it down builders or are
they just destroyers and my strong
sentiment is that they're primarily
destroyers and then you might say well
why do people wish to destroy well it's
because they're hurt by life and they're
resentful
and resentful people become vengeful and
vengeful people become dangerous and
there's no shortage of motivation to
make things worse now the school
shooters make things worse people make
things worse now you know maybe lurking
in the rhetoric is this appeal to an
egalitarian utopia but we've tried
egalitarian utopias already we
sacrificed a hundred million people to
you egalitarian utopias and we have yet
to produce one and so my sense is the
corpses stacked up high enough to
constitute proof so its destruction
mostly that motivates it as far as I can
tell masquerading as compassion
thank you for that question
next please dr. Peterson where's the
party thank you both for being here
today when political scientists would
have studied his totalitarian regimes
totalitarian regimes I've studied I
tried to look at the Iranian Revolution
and the Islamic Republic in Iran and
I've argued how the Shia Islam that is
teach in the Islamic Republic is very
close to a totalitarian regime but now I
live in a country where my ideas are
considered controversial if you believe
in God if you believe in family if you
believe in having responsibility and
traditional values
I feel ostracized by the community here
I came from UFC University of Calgary
over there I didn't feel this way there
was more welcoming here I feel
marginalized and I do feel alone and
when I see this it disgusts me they're
here they can do this but I couldn't go
to their events and do anything I'd have
to shut up there be a disciplinary
committee for me but for them they can
break windows to God knows how old this
building is and it's okay for them to do
that so my question to you is now being
here experiencing this I'm turning to
second guess it may be the totalitarian
Islamic regime that I was so you know
talking about uncritical of back in Iran
isn't so bad when I have a choice
between having to be here and be
oppressed and be there and at least have
my ideas be okay with the regime so my
argument is if this free speech and the
arguments you guys are making here
doesn't work would that not be the next
step for people to go towards
totalitarianism
if dialogue fails and isn't force of
arms the only thing left
how can people compromise when they
don't want to talk when they want to
yell thank you
[Applause]
I think you make a very good point I I
don't think we should pool ourselves
this is about force and it is it's
almost a dare to suggest that that
certain elements are not allowed to
enforce their view of the world and that
speaking contrary to it isn't an affront
to those values and they won't shut you
down I mean that that is what is at
stake we we are we are we are no longer
really in a situation where this will
all be resolved through sort of gentle
reasonable civil dialogue that that
happens on the side but it's not real
anymore it's not really where the fight
is happening this is an imposition of
the force of the state and it is skewed
it is skewed a certain way and we are
getting to the point where a certain
kind of language the curtain certain
kind of dialogue is is approved and all
right and a certain kind is not and that
is the campaign that is going on that
this is all part of and I have to say
that that your presence here and and
your endorsement that this kind of event
is the kind of thing that has the major
push back to that trend but the trend is
continuing it is a very dangerous one
and these this is a difficult moment in
the life of this country would you would
you say Jordan so so some some comments
about about your career let's say okay
so you're a young mount and you've got
lots of years ahead of you so you know
you want to prepare for the war and not
for the battle right okay because
there's going to be many battles for you
personally and perhaps politically and
all of that and so you want to make
yourself as articulate and educated as
you can and you want to have patience I
would say that there's no cause for
despair you know I believe that the
people who are attempting to radicalize
our society and to transform it into a
battleground of identity politics are in
a distinct minority and I think that I
think that there's no reason to assume
that we can't push the devil back into
the into the bottle so
to speak to push the genie back into the
bottle and so don't despair now from a
personal perspective it's like you've
got lots of things to learn and you've
got lots of things to say and to write
and you're going to find now and then
that you're imposed upon in a manner
that you don't find tolerable right you
think I can't live like this right it's
going to distress you and well then then
you've come across your moral conundrum
right it's specific to you and then you
have to that's when you have to grow up
and think strategically it's like you
decide are you willing to live under
those conditions if you're not then you
develop a strategy it's like okay I'm
going to I'm going to fight this I'm
gonna fight it carefully intelligently
thoughtfully on multiple fronts and I'm
not going to back down now you don't
make that decision lightly
you know most things you should let blow
by you because there's not that much of
you and there's lots of things but now
and then you'll find a stumbling block
that you can't get over because it hurts
you like it damages your soul that's the
right way to think about it
well then that's the time for you to put
your education to use you know and
you'll be able to do that I mean you
don't want to underestimate the utility
of deep forthright speech I don't
believe that anything can stand in its
way you have the courage of your
convictions but don't give way to
despair like this battle is by no means
over no by no means and it isn't even
obvious that the bad guys are winning so
to speak you know I mean here we are
we're having this talk the university
came out forthrightly in favor of free
speech rave for that
[Music]
no one and so far all the questions
today have been thoughtful and
intelligent you seem like informed
people it's like don't underestimate
your strengths and so and McMaster just
published a set of guidelines governing
this sort of behavior so that it will no
longer be acceptable to disrupt
perfectly reasonable proceedings on
University campuses in and so that so
that discussions like this can continue
properly I mean there's definitely a
place for give-and-take and for informed
opposition let's say but there's a
difference between informed opposition
and child childish grandstanding and I
think people know the difference between
that so don't don't be desperate about
it your battles a little courage goes a
long way right because other people see
it and there's a there is I think a
silent majority out there that is silent
and is scared but if they see courage
from somebody they respond to it well I
I think you described lawyers in a way
that appealed to me once he said I think
I know that's rare but hahaha you said
lawyers I think these are the words you
said lawyers are difficult and
emotionally stable and it's the
combination of those two things the
willingness to be difficult but not to
be emotional about it
don't-don't-don't weighed your emotions
to the fight
take a step back engage in it say what
you think be courageous
but don't get wrapped up in it don't be
emotional about it but you know retain
your strengths for the long haul yeah
well you know one of the things I've
learned strategically and this is really
worth thinking about too is that when
you're engaged in a public dispute like
this it's not obvious when things are
going your way you know you think well
this protest is not such a good thing
it's like I wouldn't be so sure about
that you know what's happened to me in
the last 18 months is that virtually
every time that I've been attacked and
some of the attacks have been quite
well I wouldn't say brutal because we
haven't got to that thank God but
they've certainly been they've taken me
about you know it's not it's not a
straightforward thing to be in a hall
with this happened at McMaster with a
hundred people yelling at you and
blaring air horns and all of that but
that wasn't a bad thing as it turned out
because it was filmed and it was put on
YouTube and it was terrible for the
people who protested you know it wasn't
good
and so you got to detach yourself to you
know if you say what you think and
you're careful about it it's gonna have
some short-term effects and it's gonna
have some medium-term effects and it's
gonna have some long-term effects and
one of the things that you need to do I
would say and this is an element of
courage is you have to have faith that
the medium to long term consequences of
you saying what you have to say as
clearly as possible is going to be
positive and you have to act on that
supposition you don't know right you
can't know that that's the existential
leap of faith is you you can't know but
you act anyway and my experience has
been that you don't want to you don't
want to make judgment too quickly
because it's not always clear when
things are going your way
so and you know you might stand up in a
class and say something that people
react negatively to II and you might get
pilloried for that by some people but
you never know who you're touching in
the crowd and you don't know how that's
going to unfold across time now you that
might be a defining moment in someone
else's life to watch you stand up and
say what you have to say so don't
underestimate the power of truth and
courage really so thank you
[Music]
honestly they should be thankful at how
civil and how peaceful you guys are they
should be thankful they shouldn't be
angry I regret to say we probably have
time for probably just a couple more
questions so let's go to the back hi
so my question is directed at dr.
Peterson I've been watching your
lectures online for a while you speak a
lot about as you speak a lot about
character archetypes and narrative and
the importance of the Jungian idea of
the personal narrative
I I'm having trouble formulating this
into a question but I guess with the
idea of archetypes in mind are you
familiar with benoît mandelbrot idea of
fractal patterns and if so what do you
think and if is there a connection there
may be to be found well there seems to
be a metaphorical connection in that the
the the great is is reproduced in the
small and that's certainly an idea that
permeates let's say religious and
Theological speculation you know there's
an idea that here's an idea that it's
like the idea of the genie which is the
reap same root word as genius you know
the genie is something of unimaginable
power that's constrained in a very small
space and that's kind of what a person
is like you know we have this affinity
we have this connection to the infinite
we have this connection to the divine
but work but it's constrained within
within our frames right and we have to
act out the divine narrative in the
confines of our own life and so there is
this overarching reality which is
something like the for the forthright
confrontation with the catastrophe of
life right and but that has to be made
personal you know so that that's one of
you I would say deepest ideas is that
the archetypal has to be made personal
in your own life and so you take the
generic pattern and you personalize it
and then the infinite and the finite
meet and that's the perfect combination
and there's something about that that's
well uh not era bleep profound I would
say and and and and as true as anything
can be
and I think people know this at a very
deep level because you do know when
you're struggling to go to sleep at
night and your conscience is bothering
you and you think through the things
that you did in the day and the week
you'll take solace and the things that
you did that we're noble and true and
you and you can you can breathe a sigh
of relief that you're not completely
corrupt and lost and then you can sleep
it's like everyone knows this well we
need to know it consciously right and
that's part of the process of making the
archetypal personal and that's part of
what the religious process is supposed
to be about is to outline the the
archetypal pattern and then to say look
you have to meditate on this and you
have to figure out how to make it true
in the confines of your own life and
that gives see the reason that works I
think is because there's no doubt that
your life is tragic and and there's no
doubt that you have a malevolent element
and that you'll be touched by betrayal
and all those terrible things but
there's a nobility about you too and
that nobility might be sufficient to
transcend your limitations and I would
say that your life is a struggle to
determine if that might be the case and
that's the act of faith but and I also
do believe I was asked today by South
African journalists if I'm the ultimate
pessimist or the ultimate optimist
you know and I would say in some ways I
am the ultimate pessimist I know I think
as much as I can tolerate how terrible
life can be but I do believe that the
human spirit can overcome that
catastrophe and can rise out of it and I
think the universities are that that
idea expressed in stone and tradition
that's a great idea everyone needs the
idea
especially people who are young you know
your life is you know that your life is
going to be difficult it's like no one
can say well it's going to be easy but
you might say well do you want it to be
easy what's in it for you if it's easy
well no you want it to be difficult and
worthwhile and you want to be the sort
of person that can manage that and
that's what you should be that's what
you should be encouraged to be at
University and and that's what the
universities are for so well that's the
archetypal and the personal I would say
yeah thank you very much this will have
to be our last question go ahead sir
in recent time I would probably identify
the most recent u.s. election is the
turning point for this and that's I've
seen that as an American citizen this is
my first time living in Canada
I've noticed that public discourse has
taken to elevate fascism as the ultimate
evil and maybe rightfully so you know
there are many horrific things committed
by fascist States in the 20th century
and you see people you know like
Facebook cover photos like bash the fash
you see let stickers on laptops this
Machine Kills Fascists
it is you know there's this big like
backlash against fascism and the horrors
that it caused but in spite of that you
don't see the same reaction to the
horrors and the genocide that were
caused by socialist and communist states
in the 20th century you do not
you see people who virtue signal
endlessly about how horrible the
Holocaust was about how awful these
things were and then just hand-wave away
the famine genocide of the Ukraine the
Great Leap Forward they think these
things are inconsequential or even
necessary sacrifices for the rise of the
greater good of socialism or communism
and I personally find that morally
reprehensible and I can't understand
where that where that comes in how you
can stand there and be so opposed to
this genocide let's say that this
genocide is somehow just oh it's not a
problem and why do you think that how do
you think that disconnect happens how do
you think people can convince themselves
of that and why do you think that
happens it's a great question you know I
have my house is covered with with art
from the Soviet era and I have a lot of
reasons for that part of it is to remind
me of what happened part of it is to
watch the struggle between the art and
the propaganda on the canvas is sort of
in real time you know I'm very
interested in that but I would never
decorate my house with Nazi regalia you
know and and you think well why is that
exactly it's not like I don't know that
what happened in the communist regimes
was utterly reprehensible why is it and
perhaps it's not acceptable to have you
know socialist realist paintings in your
house but it's certainly more acceptable
or it seems that way than to have
paintings from the Nazi era let's say so
then you think well why is that exactly
and I think you know back in 1918 at the
dawn of the Russian Revolution when
Europe was in flames and in ruins and
the monarchical societies were
collapsing and the Industrial Revolution
was in full force and there were
terrible there was terrible poverty and
terrible inequality the dream of
universal brotherhood was a compelling
dream the dream of egalitarianism and
and and maybe maybe who knows how much
of it was motivated by genuine
benevolence some at least it's very
difficult to see that the Nazi the Nazi
phenomena was ever generated by any
genuine benevolence that's very
difficult to to make a case for so maybe
you can forgive
the the Socialists the Communists
utopians a hundred years ago because
they didn't know what they were getting
in for people had warned them Dostoevsky
warned that Nietzsche warned them but
but still and then the other thing too
is the problem of inequality it's like
the problem of inequality is a real
problem and it doesn't go away like it's
very difficult when you walk down Bloor
Street for example in Toronto and you
see homeless people alcoholics and drug
addicts who are struggling and the
mentally ill who are on the street and
they're in their little domain of hell
it's it's really difficult for that to
not tear it your heartstrings and say
well isn't the world an unjust place or
an unfair place which it is and so you
can see the neverending Wellsprings of
motivation to support the oppressed and
I think the fact that the the Communists
the Communist Dogma at least had that as
part of its initiating ethos is partly
what seems to make it forgivable I also
think it's easier for people to identify
why fascism is wrong we could say look
racial superiority no ok it's pretty
simple right it's three words you can
really get it but
but but equality of outcome it's like
that's really wrong it's really wrong
but it's not so obvious why right it
isn't you can't just say quality of
outcome no and have everyone clap
because it isn't as well and that's the
thing it's really difficult to it's
difficult to isolate the pathological
elements in radical left-wing thought
because they're not self-evidently
pathological like there's this old
cliche from each according to his
ability to each according to his need
it's like yeah that sounds pretty good
we have needs it's like let's have them
fulfilled and well you have an ability
well like manifest it it's like well it
doesn't work in practice in fact its
murderous in practice and it's a great
catastrophe in some sense that it's
murderous in practice so I just think
it's maybe part of it is it's just a
hell of a lot harder to learn why it's
wrong that combined with you know the
genuine outpouring of compassion for the
oppressed and and which is like who's
for poverty no one right and an
inequality is a painful reality it's
painful for everyone you know even
people who are self-righteous about
their their status let's say in in the
depths of their soul the struggling of
the fact of the struggling still rips at
them and so it's a more difficult lesson
for us to learn so yeah
[Applause]
see those people lined up with the mic
sigh sorry for leaving you hanging I'm
sure we could go on all night if we had
the time but we must call this to a
close I would like to salute you for
your patience and your dedication in the
face of the noise from outside very
nicely done
well done
as you as you no doubt are aware
professor Peterson has written an
international bestseller it's called 12
rules for life there are some per sale
in the hall now before you go let me
just say this you have participated in
what I would consider to be an important
step in the life of this university and
for that we should thank you so thank
you for coming and thank you for your
support
professor Peterson may be the most
important intellectual voice in this
country today and I would like to thank
him very much for coming
so goodnight be safe I just have sorry I
just have one small thing to say
although I would I would very much like
to stay and talk with a bunch of you and
I generally do that but I can't do it
today because I have to go back to
Toronto and I'm going to Australia
tomorrow so I don't I can't do that even
though I would like to so I have to run
off and then I have to drive back to
Toronto and but despite that thank you
very much for coming and for being
patient and all of that yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
three three three three three treatment
show you our Queens shame on Queens no
speech have merely chosen where I'm at
with him I've been looking at his points
I'm looking at the protest point so I'm
not really sure I just think it's
interesting that he's drawing the sort
of crowd and that you know what's
happening here is happening I think that
really says something about
participation in Queens
we're here to protest Jordan Pederson
being given a platform at Queen's
University Jordan Pederson aside from
not knowing what he's talking about visa
visa law Pearson pension Titan feature
grabber to grow it's not a discussion
about which toppings you like on pizza
it's a discussion about which people
should be considered if you know which
people you should respect and that's not
a debate that should happen anywhere
[Music]
because clearly they don't agree with
what he has to say so they're showing it
but I have seen a lot of people call
cancel they are shouting that Daniel
should be ashamed of himself for
allowing this to happen and that I think
is wrong I don't know it seems like we
have a lot of very angry people here
because someone's expressing an idea
different than their own and here at a
university I kind of thought that was
thank you would you look at one more
look at this Pepsi Cola
[Applause]
it's refreshing it takes bravery to save
that haters all acceptable guys yeah
really
they brought the [ __ ] window aisle in
there
Jesus Christ Oh crazy crazy